I'm really competitive so the chance to
compete against ten-year-olds was really
enticing to me I mean these babies are
just they're gonna have to change their
diapers
[Music]
you aren't going down cuz we're breaking
three what will you up on the show we're
the originals we got this we're nineties
kids your mom here yeah she's hair let's
be very watch Dominique what animal was
considered most sacred by ancient
Egyptians cat that is correct
yay which of these was not a
contribution from ancient Rome
music correct
the Mayan civilization lasted for about
3,000 years true that is correct
yeah is it three correct we're buds
she's like there's probably like a
really smart way to do this
yeah but we're just yeah we're not
stupid yeah we're not doing it right
okay are you saying that cuz you know
girl
I think this is where my age losing my
time right a little bit
okay oh yeah I forgot this one sorry I
probably have a better literally you
I've done a lot of things that you'll
see no literally dead on Oh mines
actually really correct he's actually
really wrong how low does this thing go
we won they did it and that's all that
matters
I feel I feel okay later holding this
better wonder neck for reason we beat
you saddens me that they don't know the
importance they also didn't know you
know their place
[Music]